kids get the popcorn out let me tell you  the story of the space viking thor  odenson  he was no ordinary man  he was a god  after saving planet earth for the 500th  time thor set off on a new journey  well he got in shape  he went from dead bod  to godbod  and after all that  he reclaimed his title  as the one and only thor  oh spook too soon  jane  [Music]  the old ex-girlfriend  what's the family three four years eight  years seven months and six days give or  take  am i uh sensing feelings  [Music]  well you're right  the only ones who gods care about  is themselves  so this is my vow  all gods will die  i just want to say that was very very  impressive what you did back  there it's just my first bad guy  [Music]  you never forget you're first  [Music]  you  are  worth fighting for  [Music]  let's see who you are and take off your  disguise  and flick  oh you flick too hard damn it  should we help him mean eventually grape  [Music]